welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for marvel's moon night coming
to disney plus march 30th with oscar
isaac playing steven grant aka mark
spector aka jake lockley aka vigilante
power with the magic of an egyptian moon
deity aka
mutant it's about nur oh wait no oscar
isaac was apocalypse in another marvel
universe and the x-men won't get sucked
into the mcu until multiverse madness
when oscar isaac being moon knight in
this reality will be like the 12th most
confusing thing about that but this
trailer was filled with mystery and
tricky visual glitches in this
character's broken perception so i'm
gonna go through this frame by frame to
break down all the really cool stuff
that you might have missed and thanks to
boxu for sponsoring this video more on
them later let's get started
[Music]
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
on dreams so the trailer opens with
oscar isaac as one of his identities
lying in bed using an app that helps one
stay awake because he doesn't want one
of his other identities to take over he
twists a rubik's cube at first with just
one hand as if this is a kind of
coordination one identity might have
that another might lack later we see the
side that he is closest to completing is
the white side white being the color of
moon knight's wardrobe which in the 2006
moon night comics from charlie houston
explained i don't wear white to hide
myself i wear it so they see me coming
so they'll know who it is because when
they see the white it doesn't matter how
good of a target i am their hands shake
so bad they couldn't hit the moon i just
love that quote so much it's part of the
reason the character's so great i had to
share it with you also the toggling
colors of a rubik's cube of course
reflect the toggling of this man's
identities he suffers from a form of
dissociative identity disorder the voice
we hear right now is that of his stephen
grant identity with oscar isaac speaking
in a british accent but on the word
dreams the accent seems to switch to a
different consonant pronunciation
between my waking life
and dreams as if another identity is
taking over mid-sentence in the comics
moon knight's primary identity is mark
spector the son of a rabbi turned
mercenary who ends up possessed by the
egyptian moon deity of khonshu becoming
the vigilante known as moon knight with
powers linked with a lunar cycle and he
takes on other alter-egos like wealthy
one percent or stephen grant and taxi
driver lake lockley but obviously
they're switching some things around
here because here he bolts several locks
on his door he puts tape on the crack so
that he'll know if the seal is broken
chaining his ankle to a lock that only
one of his identities would know the
combination to the fact that he expects
this other identity to not know how to
just peel tape off of a door and put it
back on tells us that the form he is
worried about turning into is a more
monstrous one so we're looking at a real
werewolf jekyll and hyde scenario here
steven turns in his bed reflected in
mirror glass that refracts him into
three forms in total perhaps a way of
showing his two other identities and yet
he still twists around in fear as if
he's looking at a fourth identity maybe
that of moon knight as it creeps in on
him let's move on
[Music]
okay here that app service voice echoes
over itself as if this is something he
has used for countless nights and then
he bolts awake like from a nightmare but
notice how he's now wearing different
clothes than before so who knows if this
is a different night or if another
identity took over overnight and just
changed his clothes and calmly locked
himself back up and as he stumbles out
of bed he steps in a ring of sand which
he likely spread out to track any entity
going out or going in kind of like when
that couple and paranormal activity use
flour to track that demon you'll notice
among his stack of books is adventures
of the soul journeys through the
physical and spiritual dimensions this
is a real life 2014 book by medium james
van praag about the human soul how it
fits into this life how it travels into
the spirit realm so clearly steven is
doing some research on metaphysics to
try to understand his condition and how
his soul is becoming detached from his
physical body now the music throughout
this trailer is kid cudi's day and night
a song that kid cudi said that he wrote
to deal with the sleeplessness after his
uncle passed away an uncle that he ended
things on bad terms with and the song
day and night nightmare is his version
of the ghetto boy's mind playing tricks
on me the music video shows him slipping
in and out of reality the way steven
slash
jake never fully know what's real in
their world on to the next clip
i think i'm losing it
we'll catch you on
you're bloody useless
stevie stephen
okay so steven runs to catch this london
bus i'm assuming this connects to the
shot we saw in the november teaser where
his hands hit that bus except now his
hands are covered in these fancy white
gloves he could be finding himself in a
new identity as he briefly passed out
for a second could be the dressier
version of that white suit that we've
seen in the comics he works at this
museum up top it reads national art
gallery an art gallery with a historical
exhibit for ancient egypt it looks like
now i thought this was a real museum in
london but the national gallery of
london has a different architecture i
actually thought this was the british
museum but if you look at the
architecture of the british museum that
is a completely different building than
this i did some digging this is actually
budapest's museum of fine arts they use
cgi to swap out that hungarian for
english we should also be clear this is
not the same museum as the museum of
natural history where cersei and dane
whitman work in eternals but both of
these museums are in the city of london
in the mcu and i think that eternal's
post-credits scene of dane finding the
ebony blade of his family taking one
step closer to becoming the black knight
and meeting blade mahershala ali could
set up those two to join moon knight in
the future as part of an mcu midnight
sun's lineup now whereas comics steven
grant is a millionaire this steven works
at the museum gift shop under this
flirty boss donna i like how he corrects
her calling him stevie by putting on his
name tag just another example of him
having to constantly reassure himself of
his identity and in this gift shopped of
course you're surrounded by egyptian
iconography figurine of a scarab a bost
statue and these puzzles one for the
quernet mirai that's a necropolis in
luxor and then another for the book of
the dead oh yes yes yes yes the egyptian
book of the dead was a funeral text
written by priests over a thousand years
it contained magic spells in order to
assist a dead person's journey through
the underworld now that's real world
history but elsewhere in the mcu we got
another book of the dead called the dark
hold which is becoming hugely important
scene with agatha harkness and
wandavision taken by wanda to seek the
multiverse for her children and now
showing up in the trailer for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
used by doctor strange probably against
the scarlet witch's wishes now in the
comics the darkhold was drafted by a
demon named kathan who in comics canon
initially gave one to maximoff her
sorcery but in the mcu these two books
of the dead could come from the same
textual history we'll see moving on
i can't tell the difference
between my eyes
thank you
what's the contact lens
hope you find it
thanks so here in his flat steven hears
voices and then looks over in his
bathroom mirror and his reflection
flashes very briefly into his fully
suited up moon knight form complete with
glowing eyes and behind them you'll
notice the pale glow of the moon through
that fog i just like how when the
spectral form appears the moon shows up
with them this awesome flickering light
horror imagery also shows up in the far
end of this hallway leading to the
elevator where we see our first clear
shot of konshu and he looks terrifying
huge bird skull floating off the
shoulders with cobwebs dangling down a
ratty cape mummified arms and he holds a
staff with a crescent moon on the top we
actually caught what i think was our
first glimpse of khanshu back in the
first teaser that monstrous shadow
lurking behind stephen on the museum
floor as he stifled his screams but here
konchu limps down the corner toward him
linen raps dragging behind him and he
grabs that elevator door with that
mummified hand before turning into a
sweet old woman don't trust her stephen
stay back stay down yes in this clue
hunting in theory bitching i am cooking
on gas and that's because i have
upgraded my snack game if you're tired
of the same old snacks boxu is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan to your door each
themed monthly box suit takes you on a
gourmet journey through japan bok su
partners with 100 year old snack makers
to make their original treats and
support family businesses now the first
boxu you get is called seasons of japan
and it lets you taste the seasonal
flavors popular in japan every month
after that you'll receive a different
themed box like this one this month's
baksu is
pink valentine see each baksu comes with
a booklet that tells you about the
cultural theme and shares where all the
snacks come from so you got this good
stuff comes from hokkaido et cetera et
cetera i'm gonna try this one oh it's a
yummy looking little chocolate
mmm
oh this is so good it's nice and wavery
got some layers of cream in there those
are like three of my favorite different
snacks that are all in one oh i feel
like the world's valentine i mean i
gotta be honest with you guys this whole
box design is really really cute it
would make a really nice valentine's day
gift so if you want to get some awesome
japanese snacks for yourself or maybe
that special someone in your life click
the link in the description and use our
code rockstars to get 10 off your
subscription next clip
yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark
why did you call me mark okay once again
we see that great shot from the teaser
showing steven reacting to his
reflections in the display case glass
and stepping forward but his reflections
do not follow even those two reflections
between the two of them seem to have
slightly different reaction speeds from
each other i think all three of these
embody steven's split identities now the
statue in that display case depicts the
sun god of raw on the far left he is the
falcon head and then on the far right
anubis who has a jackal head both of
them appearing to mummify osiris the
deity most associated with the process
of mummification really the weirdest
things though about the shot are in the
foreground first that crocodile perhaps
a nile crocodile that you often see in
these exhibits could also connect to
that crocodile on the unknown collar
screen on the flip bone both could be
nods to amut the crocodile-headed
goddess of the underworld but also
beneath that croc there appears to be
mummified human remains on the freaking
floor and notice how steven holds his
arm as if he has been wounded or bitten
maybe this guy was doing a bit of grave
robbery and tampering with these remains
taking something off of them and
konshu's spirit jumped out and bit him
but notice as he steps forward the
shadow that stood behind him before he
steps out of frame after he passes that
shadow it is no longer there creepy now
kid cuddy's lyrics of hold the phone
repeat as if the record is skipping
until steven finally uncovers this crawl
space containing this key and the split
phone probably a phone that he heard
ringing in the walls and thought he was
paranoid but it actually is a real phone
and a key belonging to his other
identity mark spector so the character
we've been staying with this whole
trailer is not really the main character
of the story we haven't really met mark
yet which is why i love this trailer so
much i actually hope the next trailer
spends most of the time with mark who is
a badass mercenary who somehow ended up
as his pencil pushing loser in london
how long has he really been this way was
there some previous backstory that has
been erased from his memory where he
initially made first contact with konshu
back in egypt and the reason he is
working at this museum is to try to
reconnect with that spirit now the
caller on this phone is the voice of
actress mae calamali whom you may know
as rami's sister dina on rami on hulu
and the closed caption identify her
character name as layla now the most
famous layla from marvel comics is laila
miller aka the mutant butterfly who has
the power of resurrecting the dead at
the cost of their soul she actually
makes her debut in the house of m event
that we speculate multiverse of madness
to be partly adapting and layla miller
is actually crucial to bringing down the
house of m because she uses her power to
restore the memories of superheroes and
she helps restore the reality doctor
strange even suggests that wanda maximum
fighting created layla as a fail-safe to
help the heroes in case something went
wrong sure this could just be like annie
layla but meg calamali is such a great
actress it'd just be really cool to see
her play a similar role in an mcu house
of them event so let's move on that must
be very difficult
a voice
in your head
shut up
this chaos
[Music]
okay here we meet ethan hawk's character
a cult leader that hawks city based on
david koresh leader of the branch
davidians in waco texas but the closed
captioning identifies him as arthur
harrow who's a pretty deep cut from the
moon night comics who only shows up in
one issue a story line in 1985 where dr
arthur harrow was a mad scientist with a
facial disfigurement who works on a way
to numb the pain centers of the human
body conducting some human experiments
based in his work on nazi experiments
now ethan hawk's version of the
character seems quite different but
maybe his motive is the same he could be
a spiritual leader promising people who
suffer pain to numb their pain centers
and i'm guessing all these people
kneeling to him in germany loki style
that this guy's got the goods he has
some kind of power now this town square
does have german signs and a cupcake
delivery truck that a major sequence
later takes place upon those colorful
buildings could actually be seen in the
background of the november teaser shot
where mark comes too after beating up a
bunch of guards and now surrounding
harrow are some armed guards that might
be part of his cult that suggests his
cult is a militarized one these guys
wear matching jean vests in layers
underneath those vests that match the
color that harrow wears now in the moon
knight comics many of moon knight's foes
had nazi links since the character's
jewish upbringing was a big part of his
conflicts maybe harrow in this show is
also rooted in those nazi experiments
and this cult could be on some old nazi
compound in bavaria harrow tells stephen
there's chaos in you suggesting he does
have some perceptive abilities and could
see the demonic possession inside of
steven and yeah this is happening in
that museum could it be by happenstance
that they met or was harrow seeking the
same thing that mark spector kissed by
this demon is also unconsciously seeking
then another shot of stephen flipping
out while someone talks to him in the
foreground could be talking to himself
like this could be taking place inside
of steven stephen
jake's mind palace where the other two
identities have to hang out when they're
not in the driver's seat then this great
shot on the cupcake delivery truck as it
speeds down that mountain road and
steven mark jake comes too shocked at
the gun in his hand in his current
situation
the truck's windshield has been blown
out his face and knuckles are covered in
blood just like they were in that teaser
shot now that box behind him reads von d
the rest of the name cut off and yes i
did lose my mind too for a second
thinking this could be victor von doom
but i am sorry to disappoint you it is
just the name of the cupcake distributor
which you can see on other boxes in the
back it looks like vaughn darylman but
also in the back that dude's face looks
gnarly either a cupcake might have
smeared on his face or he's bleeding
heavily from the head or maybe both it's
just super violent to see this guy who
might have been shot in the head about
to roll out the back of the car under
these two pursuing cars you'll notice
they're driven by guys wearing the same
kind of outfit he is so i guess steven
beat them all up trying to get to hero
and now they're chasing them down and i
guess this will lead to steven
completely falling off a cliff though
presumably he's going to transform into
moon 9 midfield and manage to stick
superhero landing on to the next clip
embrace the chaos
[Music]
okay we see the great pyramids of egypt
and then i'm guessing this is mark
spector inside of a temple or a tomb i
think this could be part of a buried and
semi-forgotten backstory when mark
spector was still in that identity that
stephen grant does not remember as his
steven grant identity working as a loser
in this museum gift shop it's going to
be in this museum where he reconnects
with konshu that awakened steven grant
to remember that he had this whole past
as a mercenary and an indiana jones type
badass so he thought his whole life he's
been a loser but through his
dissociative identity disorder he's
gonna remember how much of a killer he
actually is i love how as we see him
fleeing down this hallway conscious form
trails at his feet in the form of that
crescent-shaped shadow the mere hero's
voice advising embraced the chaos and
then another mirror shot as steven
throws his head back to allow moon
knight to take over i love this you can
see the linen wraps assemble over
shoulders each tiny fiber piecing
together this looks like the bathroom
that later appears busted as he beats up
that creature but we actually see a
similar moment where this happens
outside it's just so cool to see how
this works like the moon knight identity
is mummifying his body to transport him
into the land of the dead but just for
the night and in this exterior shot some
shadowy figure is watching this happen
from the lower right corner of the frame
but we end on this awesome shot now we
did see moon knight pummeling something
in the november teaser but that shot was
not finished and now we see what they
added in he's beating up some
supernatural creature with freakishly
long legs huge canine feet and pointy
ears now my first instinct goes to
werewolf because the mcu is soon going
to introduce us to werewolf by night
jack russell carol garcia bernal in an
upcoming halloween special it sounds
like but i think a likelier option is
this could be a jackal form as seen in
the god of the dead anubis and as moon
knight turns to camera a few of those
linen wraps stretch across his chest to
hold the crescent moon sigil in place i
love how practical that all is actually
this shape looks like the crescent dart
weapon that he uses as we saw in that
series poster that i love so much now we
are going to be covering moon night
weekly when it drops on march 30th but
until then support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
me rockstars and subscribe to the
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
and uh wow yeah i somehow made it
through this whole video without
mentioning my pisto that was not easy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]